we're in christmas mode here and it
feels like the holidays everybody
we're in our last week of fall as we
look outside it is very crisp and it
is cold out there we've got temperatures
in the 30s as that
sun is coming up and we'll have plenty
of sunshine i do want to urge everybody
please make sure that your sprinklers
are set to water during the daytime
hours
well after that sun has come up if
you're watering
right now or in the overnight hours with
these temperatures that have been close
to freezing in some neighborhoods
you are going to have icy sidewalks or
driveways no watering of course on
sundays
and it's been so windy maybe you've
turned your sprinklers off
to avoid water waste good for you you
can always make up for that with hand
watering
look at these chilly 30s across the
valley 20s up at kyle canyon
and pahrump it's been in the 20s as well
as mesquite
clouds are already coming in to the
coast that's our next system
that will be here tomorrow and bring us
more clouds starting tonight
breezy southwest winds tomorrow so enjoy
the sunshine and lighter winds highs
near 60 today
62 tomorrow cooler 50s again friday and
saturday
winter begins on monday we'll get back
to some milder mid 60s as we head
towards christmas
next week let's get